I want to follow up on something I sort
of started talking about last week last
week during the notable reddit
discussion story there was a post I
mentioned on our subreddit called is the
left taking anti-semitism seriously
enough and there's actually a bigger
specific story here which is that of
louis farrakhan's involvement in the
women's march the women's march has been
a remarkable example of activism in the
trump era even if i've had specific
criticisms of some particular marches in
the past the political engagement that
trump has catalyzed is great of course
assuming it leads to voter turnout
increases in 2018 and it moves the
needle in terms of getting these
right-wing nuts out of elected office
but the women's March big picture is a
really great thing despite my sort of
micro criticisms of it but the women's
March has some major problems and one of
those problems is something that I've
identified among a strain of the left
for a long time and to put it in the
most charitable terms it's the
indifference to extremely anti-semitic
elements in their ranks many of the
women's March leaders are directly
connected to one of the most notorious
anti anti-semites in American culture
from the last several decades and that
is the leader of the Nation of Islam
Louis Farrakhan and this guy is
undoubtedly a massive anti-semite a
disgusting and vile Jew hater both the
anti-defamation league and the Simon
Wiesenthal Center are unequivocal on
this and it's not a new thing right you
go back to 1985 and Farrakhan said of
the Jews and don't you forget when it's
God who puts you in the ovens it's
forever skip ahead 30 years to March of
2015
Farrakhan accused Jews of being involved
in the September 11th attacks Farrakhan
is called Adolf Hitler a very great man
in his speech last month he described
the powerful Jews as his enemy and he
actually sort of looked back
nostalgically at the anti-jewish
statements of President Richard Nixon
and the Reverend Billy Graham who recent
we passed away it's a very very long
list and the Nation of Islam is an
organization which he leads and it's all
just filled with rampant anti-semitism
there's no denying that and three of the
women involved at the top level of the
women's march are directly tied to
Farrakhan Linda Sarsour Carmen Perez and
Tameka Mallory and I have said for years
that anti-semitism is a blind spot for
some left-wing activists and this came
to a head last week when Farrakhan as I
mentioned spoke at the Nation of Islam's
saviors day and he again talked about
Satanic Jews saying when you want
something in this world the Jews hold
the door white folks are going down and
Satan is going down and Farrakhan by
God's grace has pulled the cover off of
that satanic Jew and I'm here to say
your time is up this is the
anti-semitism and the straight-up racist
nonsense that this guy has been
perpetrating for decades
anyone with actual progressive values or
any Western liberal values whatsoever
should condemn it and it should have the
women's March should have nothing to do
whatsoever with Louis Farrakhan or with
his organization the Nation of Islam but
this is barely registering with some of
these so-called
leftists some examples Tameka Mallory
recently asked about Farrakhan
statements and here's what she came up
with on Twitter the black community is
very complex we have been and continue
to suffer through incomparable
circumstances this means other people
may not understand how we organize and
all that it takes to deal with our pain
I am dedicated to bringing people
together however I will not be bullied
presumably into denouncing Louis
Farrakhan so we have to understand that
part of the black community dealing with
its trauma is to accept an insatiable
and violent Jew hater like Louis
Farrakhan Jew hatred from Louis
Farrakhan is necessary to work through
the in justices that have been
perpetrated on the African American
community
that's not my flavor of the left it
never will be and I'm sorry if that
anger
I mentioned Carmen Perez she was asked
about Louis Farrakhan and his connection
to the women's March and she said in
regards to Minister Farrakhan I think
that is a distraction people need to
understand the significant contributions
that these individuals have made to
black and brown people there are no
perfect leaders we follow the legacy of
dr. King which is King and non-violence
we say we have to attack the forces of
evil not the people doing evil
we never attack people well then it
sounds like Louis Farrakhan's ideas are
merely not compatible with the ideas
that you're claiming to follow and you
should make that clear and show that
that level of hatred has no place at the
women's March to say that Farrakhan is a
distraction is just not adequate how can
we on the Left correctly criticize the
alt-right for there's ties to and their
indifference to ties to white
nationalists without denouncing and
ostracizing and alienating someone like
Louis Farrakhan who makes statements
that are very similar to the
anti-semitic conspiracy theories we hear
from the alt-right when on the right
they admire Hitler we say oh that's a
discrediting point of view yet we have
someone on the supposed left in Louis
Farrakhan who said Hitler was great and
you have the leaders of the women's
March refusing to denounce him and his
connection to the March that's not a
part of the left that I'm ever going to
be a part of now I already know I know
that the reaction to this commentary I'm
ready for it
I'm gonna get emails from people saying
David you're ignoring the good things
Farrakhan has done for the
african-american community that will be
a sort of lighter criticism I will be
called a white supremacist or I will be
called misogynistic or racist because I
am telling women what they quote should
do that is absolutely ridiculous that is
the exact type of attempt to silence
someone based on identity that the left
is supposed to be against and if these
women's March leaders were tied to
someone who had made equivalent comments
to Farrakhan's
about black people about Hispanic people
about foreigners or the disabled or
whatever a group of people this would
not be accepted but that's
exactly why we need to make sure that
this blind spot for anti-semitism on the
left is not ignored that's what I'm
doing and you know what I'm ready I'm
ready for the comments I'm going to get
from people saying David you don't have
a right to say that what you're saying
is white supremacist what you're saying
is misogynistic no what I'm saying is
Louis Farrakhan is a disgusting
anti-semite and no one on the Left who
is looking to create a movement that is
respected should have any association
with this guy whatsoever those are the
facts and if you want to try to
discredit me based on my identity I'm
ready for it I'm not gonna be surprised
but I I don't really think that that's
an argument today's program is sponsored
in part by Blink 'us the entire idea
behind blinka stand the service they
provide is perfect for me
and I assume really great for a lot of
people in our audience too if you watch
this show you know I read a lot of
nonfiction books and blink astiz an app
that takes nonfiction books and it
distills the most important points and
insights from the book down to a
powerful package of information which
can be read or listened to in about 15
minutes on your mobile device or tablet
you can zip through books really quickly
I still think it's great to absorb the
wisdom of books by reading them slowly
and in their entirety deep reading is
what it's called but not everybody I
know I don't have the time to read all
the nonfiction books that I really want
to so for the ones I can't read blink
astiz the next best thing
huge selection for one low flat rate you
get access to thousands of books you can
switch between text and audio both
online and offline and you also get
personalized recommendations based on
books you've already chosen join over 4
million people already using bling cos
that made the iTunes best apps of 2017
list it's free to try but you can also
get a 20% discount on a yearly
membership by visiting blinkers comm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube we've put a link in the
description underneath the video again
that's blinking comm forward
/pa que mas